wide open 3 pointer first three of the
game for the Warriors and the paint
courage got it right back off the fancy
little shovel from draymond Green and he
won't let it flops where is this
building last times right to answer
curry does you guys you got to be closer
to him if you're jealous we don't want
him walking into threes
this kid has special skills the main
guys you got to contain right now pigma
doll was saying hey he touched the ball
it's out on him and meanwhile there's a
step curry 3 being hit when he has taken
it to the hole to throw it down who
throws it down he's not messing around
is he long 3 curry he's had to take it
Cleveland leaps with a rebound trying to
feed the ball that Jordan had Jerebko
among others just gum up the works
[Applause]
all night long seven out of 11 on
Three's even with the quick defense
finney-smith right on curry heats rules
of three grants back in 24 points in the
game turtle attack to his total and he
does it's 38 now for curry
[Music]
[Applause]
such a quick release it is temporary
have given Golden State the lead again
the defect was pretty good after the guy
standing that far out
you're not expected in before the sugar
but when you got each step
once you cross half-court generation
[Music]
once across half court engine noise